[موسيقى]
بلد سادوس وليست بلده لان سادوس بن شيبان
وابن ذهل من بكر بن وائل ابناء عم لبني
حنيفه سميت هذه البلده باسمه هذه البلده
واربه في التاريخ قبل سادوس نفسه
والدليل على ذلك القصر الذي وجد فيها ونسب
الى النبي سليمان عليه السلام لكنه للاسف
ازيل ثم ازيل بعده
المسله او الاسطوانه او العمود الاسطوانه
الضخمه الى قبل 150 سنه كانت موجوده وتكلم
عنها
ازيلت لانه كان بعض الاجانب يزورونها ولما
كثروا الاجانب هكذا يقال قاموا اهل البلده
فهدموها واخذوا صخورها بنوا فيها ابار
وبنوا اكيد ان الصخور موجوده الان
[موسيقى]
ادله كثيره تدل على اقدميه بلد سدوس وهي
النقوش الثموديه الكثيره كم نقش موجود في
سدوس وايضا لا نستطيع ان نلم كل النقوش
الموجوده ايضا في العيينه وفي وادي حنيفه
كل يوم العرض اليمامه كله
في سدوس عثرت من ثلاثين عام على 22 نقش في
السلسله الشماليه لسادوس
ونقش ورسوم في جنوب سادوس في قاره عصيدان
ونقوش في اسفل الوادي وهذا النقش اللي نحن
نقف بجانبه الان عثر عليه الاستاذ محمد
الحمود وقراه
الدكتور بروفيسور سليمان الذيب
وقراءته هي
بلد بلد ابنه زد ابن زيد ابن زيد او زيد
يعني علم اسم علم اسم رجل او ست
[موسيقى]